so
one of the observations as one little
ant
slash human that i am of disappointment
is the political division
over information
that has been observed that i observed
this year
that it seemed the discussion was less
about
sort of what happened and understanding
what happened deeply
and more about there's different
truths out there and it's like a
argument my truth is better than your
truth
and it's it's like red versus blue or
different like it was like this
ridiculous
discourse that doesn't seem to get at
any kind of notion of the truth
it's not like some kind of scientific
process even science got politicized in
ways that's very
heartbreaking to me uh you have an
exciting project on the ai
front uh of trying to
rethink one of the you mentioned
corporations
there's one of the other collective
intelligence systems that have emerged
through all of this
is social networks and just to spread
the internet
is is the spread of information on the
uh the internet our ability to share
that information
there's all different kinds of news
sources and so on and so you said like
that's from first principles
let's rethink how we think about the
news
how we think about information can you
talk about this
uh amazing effort that you're
undertaking oh i'd love to
this has been my big covet project
nights and weekends on ever since
the lockdown to segue into this actually
let me come back to what you said
earlier that you
had this hope that in your experience
people who you felt were very talented
or often
idealistic and wanted to do good frankly
i feel the same about all people
by and large there are always exceptions
but i think the vast majority of
everybody regardless of education and
whatnot
really are fundamentally good right so
how can it be
that people still do so much nasty stuff
right
i think it has everything to do with
this with the information that we're
given
yes you know if you go into sweden
500 years ago and you start telling all
the farmers that those danes in denmark
they're so
terrible people you know and we have to
invade them yes
because they've done all these terrible
things that you can't fact check
yourself
a lot of people swedes did that right
and it
and um we've seen we're seeing
so much of this today in the world
both geopolitically you know where we
are told that that
china is bad and russia is bad and
venezuela is bad and people in
those countries are often told that we
are bad and we also see it at a
micro level you know where people are
told that oh those who voted for the
other party are bad people
it's not just an intellectual
disagreement but they're
bad people and we're getting ever more
divided
and so how do you reconcile this with
with this
intrinsic goodness i and people i i
think it's pretty obvious
that it has again to do with this with
the information that we're fed
and given right we evolved to live in
small groups where you might know 30
people in total right so you
then had a system that was quite good
for assessing who you could trust and
who you could not and if someone told
you that
you know joe there is a jerk
but you had interacted with him yourself
and seen him in action
and you would quickly realize maybe that
that's actually not
quite accurate right but now that we the
most people on the planet are people
we've never met
it's very important that we have a way
of trusting the information we're given
and so okay so where does the news
project come in well
throughout history you can go read
machiavelli you know from the 1400s and
you'll see how already then they were
busy manipulating people with propaganda
and stuff
propaganda is not new
at all and the incentives to manipulate
people is
just not new at all what is it that's
new
what's new is machine learning meets
propaganda
that's what's new that's why this has
gotten so much worse you know
some people like to blame certain
individuals like
in my liberal university bubble many
people blame donald trump and say it was
his fault
i see it differently i think
what donald trump just had this extreme
skill at playing this game
in the machine learning algorithm age
a game he couldn't have played you know
10 years ago so what's changed what's
changes
well facebook and google and other
companies and
i don't i'm not bad mapping them i have
a lot of friends who work for these
companies
good people they deployed machine
learning algorithms
just to increase their profit a little
bit to just maximize the time
people spent watching ads and they had
totally underestimated how effective
they were going to be this was again
the black box non-intelligible
intelligence
they just noticed oh we're getting more
ad revenue great it took a long time
until they even realized why
and how and how damaging this was for
society
because of course what the machine
learning figured out was
that the by far most effective way of
gluing you to your little rectangle
was to show you things that triggered
strong emotions anger
etc resentment and uh
if it was true or not didn't really
matter it was also easier to find
stories that weren't true
if you weren't limited that's just the
limitations let's show people
that's a very limiting fact and before
and
long we've got these amazing filter
bubbles on a scale we had never seen
before
it coupled this to the fact that also
the online news media were so effective
that they
killed a lot of print journalism there's
only there's
less than half as many journalists now
in america i believe
as there was you know a generation ago
he just couldn't compete with the online
advertising
so all of a sudden most people
are not getting even reading newspapers
they get get their news from social
media
and most people only get news in their
little bubble
so along comes now some people like
donald trump
who figured out among the first
successful politicians to figure out how
to really play this new game
and become very very influential but i
think donald trump was a sim
well he he took advantage of it he
didn't
create the fundamental conditions were
created by
machine learning taking over the news
media
so this is what motivated my little
covid project here so
you know i said before machine learning
and tech in general is not evil
but it's also not good it's just a tool
that you can use
for good things or bad things and as it
happens
machine learning and news was mainly
used by the big players
big tech to manipulate people and to
watch as many ads as possible
which have this unintended consequence
of really screwing up our democracy into
and fragmenting it into filter bubbles
so i thought well
machine learning algorithms are
basically free they can run on your
smartphone for free also if someone
gives them away to you right
there's no reason why they only have to
help the big guy
to manipulate the little guy they can
just as well help the little guy
to see through all the manipulation
attempts from the big guy so
this project is called you can go to
improve the news.org
the first thing we've built is that it's
a little news aggregator
looks a bit like google news except it
has these sliders on it to help you
break out or your filter bubble
so if you you're reading you can click
click and go to your favorite topic
and then um if you just slide the left
right slider away all the way over to
the left
there's two sliders right yeah there's
the one the most obvious one is the one
that has left right labeled on it
you go to left you get one set of
articles you go to the right you see a
very different truth yeah appearing oh
that's literally
left and right on the political spectrum
on the political yeah so if you're
reading about
immigration for example it it's very
very
noticeable and and i think step one
always if you want to
not get manipulated it's just to be able
to recognize
the techniques people use so it's very
helpful to just see
how they spin things on the two sides
i think many people are under the
misconception that the main problem is
fake news
it's not uh we i had an amazing team of
mit students
where we did an academic project to use
machine learning to detect
the main kinds of bias over the summer
and yes of course sometimes there's fake
news where someone just
claims something that's false right
like oh hillary clinton just got
divorced or something yes
but what we see much more of is actually
just omissions
if you go to uh there's some stories
which just won't be mentioned by the
left or the right because it doesn't
suit their agenda
and then they'll instead mention other
ones very very very much
so for example we've we've had
a lot a number of stories about
the trump family's financial dealings
and then there's been some a bunch of
stories about the biden families hunter
binds financial dealings right
surprise surprise they don't get equal
coverage on the left and the right
right one side loves to cover the biden
hunter biden stuff and one side loves to
cover the trump
never guess which is which right yeah
but the great news is if you want to if
you're a
normal american citizen and you dislike
corruption in all its forms
then slide slide you can just get look
at both of the
sides and you'll see all the corrupts
those political corruption stories
you